(light piano music)
- [Voiceover] Aleppo Citadel,
the Ancient City of Palmyra,
and the Norias of Hama;
all ancient heritage sites
and all destroyed in the Syrian War.
It's a loss, not only to
Syrians but to the entire world,
and these refugee artists
are finding their own way
to rebuild what has been lost.
- [Voiceover] They have been
using found materials such as:
wood, clay, and even kebab skewers
to make scale models of
these historical landmarks.
- [Voiceover] Their work is a
way to preserve Syrian history
and educate the world about the conflict.
- [Voiceover] The artists say
that by making this work
they are drawing attention
and giving what they can
to the people of Syria.